welcome to this video I'm playing
Blackie against luckily Xiao from Russia
name in them I like say a rash net
something sorry ok let's see makeda the
Evans gambit playing playing this line I
can also take that's much sharper but
this is a conservative way to play
giving giving back the pawn in them in
the process now what what can just take
on e5 and get the palm back which is
okay for him it's it's about equal or
you can give this check of course knight
c6 after d5 loses a piece but I can go
see 6 the night on 85 is not problematic
peace yeah maybe I played this attached
to proclaim Quincy 7 Bishop f4 could be
a could be problematic
maybe mmm wow this was good this will be
if this will get tricky he has Bishop f4
but I don't have I didn't have no talent
of now there's various various
discoveries threatened if I go can I go
be five and then move the Queen maybe he
looks very scary but it seemed to be
still okay um Bishop d6 yeah he can he
can get it back then but rook takes an
IG six if everything else fails right
there is a really dangerous discovery
night g six maybe hmm
see threatening something maybe a form I
can so maybe maybe go for that why not
take here that the dark squares IAM the
dark squares look look a bit scary this
wasn't a good idea probably my position
looks a bit uncoordinated to put it
mildly especially on the dark squares
it's possibly see for coming my very bad
disposition wow what a game again yeah I
just completely miss played this opening
that's really very bad position how do I
get some pieces out this one's probably
right into Bishop d6 at some stage yeah
this was an additional problem but
yeah Hafner wolf this is mine this is
really bad a six ball I'm in some sort
of deadly pin then be five is also just
hanging
yeah I don't even see a way to continue
him it's just it's just losing wow what
a bad game terrible you have 56 I mean
how can I allow that this route d6
really bad ok there's some way to
continue this Bishop here can I go here
somewhere then we should be 6 and time
morning you look here so that I can move
the night I mean nothing its roots
really unimportant this is just lost in
so many ways can also simply play see
for him maybe that's not the easiest way
to do it get 95 don't think it it helps
much but
maybe I can get some faint hope of
activity I get the night somewhere to
exchange stuff not really
yeah talk about ugly this is one of the
ugliest positions that i have had in a
while one one of the ways not not one of
the best ways even I think this was in
fact a blonde I am I can take here maybe
take on III
check yeah now i'm p sub check
unfortunately i don't have much time but
the position is very nice of course I
even get coming straight yet check check
check check check check check check
check
yeah close just two or three moves I
lost I lost some moves and in the
process but it was okay i mean yeah well
he he just didn't put me away I mean it
was to completely lost he had nights he
falls even possible okay yeah after he
got the winning position here he really
didn't you really stop playing good
moves and this is this is just not
necessary can just take him and of
course I mean I'm alive again very much
alive and you can just play this
position with this is even good for
black that's a good end game with the
beep on okay well this is just this is
just just blundering it away maybe I can
try to mate mmm but okay I was content
with with getting getting the endgame
check should I shall manage in 20
seconds check okay I cannot really
cannot really be too critical he I mean
I was having and always didn't didn't
spoil the position at some point I just
lost some josh is bound to happen with
no time okay very good pre mover can can
manage that but I didn't oh yeah and you
need to check what what went wrong there
check what the way I need to add it to
flick in b5 yeah absolutely i need to
play b5 and not castles this is a this
is really a big difference I need to
play b5 first or queen c7 here I don't
know but not this this is now really
very some
maybe queen bee six star yeah after this
I'm in big trouble I mean here I don't
really have a great move that's this 96
idea and yeah the comp wants to play it
wants to play actually what I did no
here it's terrible the dark squares what
the ruin or poor yeah terrible opening
result I must play b5 beforehand so
let's say let's say here even I could I
could do this here and something like
that so that Bishop f4 is no move
because of Bishop p6 I must make sure
that the night retreats and then
something like this this is ok I have
returned the pawn and I have a decent
structure this is playable it's
somewhere between equal and a slight
edge for white due to the extra send up
one but nothing spectacular ok thanks
for watching